everything I said to her according to
the way her mindset works told her that
I had to be white but it also said
something else if you're black you can't
achieve these things based on the way
she thinks which is insulting hey I'm
Dave Rubin and before we get to business
today just a quick reminder to click
that subscribe button and the little
bell there so that you actually might
get notified about our videos you know
as long as we're doing them you may as
well see him all right joining me today
is the host of the aptly titled david
webb show on Sirius XM and reality check
on fox nation and an old buddy of mine
David Webb finally 2ds together again to
David's
we'll see what happens here so it is
actually I just said to you before we
started I mean I've been doing this show
now some version of this for five plus
years I don't know how you have not
stepped in the studio I mention you
often and we're good buddies and we go
back a while but our pads yeah I think
both our audiences are wondering who the
other one is yeah well you know like is
you touchdown and I'm taking off oh
alright uh CH down and you're taking off
and for everybody watching literally you
and I said where are you I'm landing I
already know I'm at the airport going
here and this has happened so many times
it's not even funny yeah alright we've
done yeah so we have an interesting
history together because when we got to
know each other was about seven eight
years ago we were both on sirius XM you
were on the Patriot Channel as you as
you still are I was on the out Q channel
because right where they put the gay
people I wanted to be on a political and
to be in your box yes because equal my
friends equal channel but set but they
had us also in the corner was a little
weird but I really wanted to be on one
of the political channels and I met with
all the mayor and I said I'll do the you
know at the time I was a lefty so I
wanted to do the lefty but I said there
was a POTUS was sort of the non partisan
I said I'll even do the right channel
and let me be the lefty on the right
channel they kept me on the gay channel
so be it but you were the first guy
there we must have I don't even remember
how we met probably just in the hallway
and we started talking politics and you
knew we had some differences it was very
obvious and some similarity
and just a similarities more more now
right but basically I started doing your
show every couple weeks and we would
talk about all our differences we never
punched each other often we'd go out for
bourbon or a steak after it might have
been a bourbon or today I think you have
a very high level of perfect but that
almost feels like a another time already
when people used to do that yeah and
here we are today in an environment
where yeah it's become more polarized
but I've also seen more people move to
the center and I think that people can
focus on the polarization they can say
okay you're either this or you're that
but look around the country and talk to
the people you work with talk to the
people you interact with you work out
with whatever and you find that more
people is starting to drift into the
center and maybe deliberately pull
others with them saying hang on a second
let's pick an idea or values over a
party and I like that look I'm a
Republican and I tweeted this out I was
a Republican because my parents taught
me and I paraphrase it myself which is
probably quoting myself which is no
longer plagiarism but I basically said
you know what they said think about your
values what fits and make your choice
they didn't say this is your choice
because what do we get from our parents
typically you get a sports team maybe a
religion you know couple of key things
cuz that's what you grow up with and I
wish more people had that I made my
choice and they respected my choice
because I could explain why yeah and I
think we're getting back to that for
many people and they're just sick of the
you know you got to be in your outcue
box at that time and I got to be in my
patriot box they lo I don't know if you
knew this when we launched a studio 54
channel and Dave gorab was talking about
it were joking I said Dave what exact
it's serious and we both know great guy
and the guy called my boss and he says
you can't do studio 54 and it wasn't a
bad thing you know it's cuz everybody
knows on the Patriot Channel I said what
do you think we all were conservative it
without a party side right you know it's
just we don't fit and you and I didn't
yeah you know we definitely knew it all
and and and not fitting is actually the
cool thing and and I think you're right
it is the new thing and people are sort
of exhausted by those two crazy things
so I have to ask you one thing which I
hate to ask we'll just do it for a
second here all right according to this
thing here you're black is that right
well that depends on who you talk is
that a teaser for because you're a
conservative and still no matter how
many black conservatives I meet and
there are so many of them obviously in
the color of your skin should have
nothing to do with your political
beliefs somehow if you're a black
conservative they think of you you're an
anomaly
you've got Stockholm Syndrome i-i've
heard it all yeah you know first
perspective if you go to a country
that's a majority black country or a
Caribbean island some of the islands
have more conservative majorities or
conservative values and thoughts aren't
there mostly black people there that's
all out there too right so that's my
point is so you go to a country which is
70 percent 72% self-identified white if
you want to look at America and you've
got breakups of different ethnicities
and mix in whatever so suddenly being
black is really an anomaly it's not
because the problem with identity
politics is it's based on this box
you're supposed to be in and you and I
are talking about what do you believe in
and that's the difference and that's why
I like listening to you that's why you
and I get along because we found our
similarities our differences and we
respect the fact that people come at
things from different lanes and a lot of
times they want to get to a similar
similar end similar solution yeah the
ones that don't want to get to the end
of the highway don't want to get to the
end of you know this series of lanes
they're the ones that are dishonest yeah
those are usually the ones that want to
control you somehow yeah because I mean
come on you're Dave you're supposed to
think this way and you look a certain
way and you know Wow why are you this
way but you know what more people over
the years even though me and what I did
the night show and whether it was
talking politics or values or talking
about drinking a bourbon on the air or
having a piece of pizza
people came along for what was there in
the show and then I would hear from them
here wow I finally saw you on TV you're
black and then their next comment
well it doesn't matter to me so there's
an incredible I think one of the most
incredible moments in media in the last
year happened on your show this is what
about six seven months ago something
like that yeah it's about seven yeah
yeah you had a Reva Martin on Arriva
Martin's a CNN contributor I'm friendly
with her she was on my show a couple
years ago on the Rubin report and she's
a she's a progressive she went on your
show and well why don't we just play the
audio I've chosen across different parts
of the media world done the work so that
I'm qualified to be in each one I never
considered my color the issue I
considered my qualifications the issue
well David you know that that's a whole
nother long conversation about white
privilege and things that you have the
privilege of doing that as people of
color don't have the privilege of how do
I have the Rivlin of white privilege
David by virtue of being a white male
you have white privilege whole long
conversation I don't have time Arriva I
hate to break it to you but you should
have been better prepped I'm black okay
then I you went to white privilege this
is the fall suit in this you went
immediately with an assumption your
people obviously or you didn't look
you're talking to a black man who
started out in rock radio in Boston who
crossed the paths into hip-hop
rebuilding one of the greatest black
stations in America and went on to work
for Fox News where I'm told apparently
blacks aren't supposed to work but yet
you come with this assumption and you go
to white privilege because my people
gave me wrong information they told me
the whole white privilege thing is
Indian I apologize correct the record I
want to apologize I was given wrong
information about you and I upon my
color you were going to something that I
was part of and just to add to it my
family background is white
black Indian Arawak Irish Scottish I
mean it's so diverse I'm like the UN
when it comes to this and this is part
of the problem with driving a narrative
around a construct like white privilege
privilege is one thing were applied
wealth economy various social factors
but not necessarily determined by color
of skin to me that is everything I have
spent the last few years of my life
talking about in a perfect wrapped
package it was a gift on a slow Tuesday
it really was the quick version you know
of the backstory of this one they
pitched my producers to come on my show
and when you get a pitch you look up
your guest you go ok what have they
written what stories one of they
appeared Google Don whatever search
engine you get some information and
somewhere along the way you'd find out
that oh that's the david webb happens to
be a black guy that's not what happened
here
they pitched me she came on we had a I
don't know we'll say this we had a good
conversation about William Bars
nomination and everything in the
differences of opinions on jury you know
jurisprudence and other things and then
it went to this idea where we talked
about success and all of these issues
that led to her commentary and I said to
her I said look I started out and my
color wasn't the factory just heard that
started out in rock radio went through
all these things and I realized after
when I went back I listened to
everything I said to her according to
the way her mindset works told her that
I had to be white but it also said
something else if you're black you can't
achieve these things based on the way
she thinks which is insulting it's sad
it's a sort of soft bigotry of low
expectation based on the color of your
skin and then everybody's heard it she
threw her team under the bus yeah they
didn't hold the line though that you're
her team wasn't it didn't Informer
didn't I
that is that what there's well maybe in
the progressive world they go well this
person's gay and this person's black
right you know that actually would be a
cohesive way to go on a show but can you
imagine what happened she's there doing
an interview did somebody go and slide a
piece of paper over that said he's white
yeah and now you've got a white guy she
heard the things that fed what she
expected of a white person but never
thought anyone can achieve this and
that's the difference between me you and
her so I so I don't want to in any way
sue she's not here to defend yourself so
I don't want to make this too much about
her but but that mindset do you think
that after you've said well you know I'm
black and the rest of it do you think
that that might have dinged her way of
thinking a little bit I think it got
through to people online cuz that clip
went viral
because I couldn't see each other it was
such a perfect example of what we're
always talking about well did it change
her mind I don't know and look you and I
think agree on the fairness of being
there to defend yourself but what I did
offer her was a conversation and in the
second clip that doesn't get as much
attention and I've played it on radio we
play it on television I asked her to
come back and give I said I'll offer you
an hour come back we'll talk about white
privilege and she accepted so my team
sent an email as a follow up request in
her appearance and when I was asked on
television do you accept her apology
because she gave that half-hearted
apology yeah it wasn't really about it
wasn't really an apology it was a
deflection which is different than an
apology obviously when when she did that
I gave her the chance for conversation
when I was asked do you accept her
apology I said I really don't but what
I'm offering her is a conversation and I
have offered her the chance to come back
and she never came back so the story's
not just a clip of what she said and why
she said it but the fact is that she
avoided the conversation that was
offered based on what she asked for
yeah and what she agreed to and that to
me is a level of and I have to say
dishonesty
because if someone does that to me you
know what I'm gonna be mad
enough or maybe a host enough or a guest
enough whatever term you want to use to
go in and say I'm gonna come and present
my point and defend it if I believe in
it yeah well it just so it shows what I
would say is just the thinness of the
argument because she could make an
argument with her preconceived notions
once they were blown apart you say all
right let's let's talk it out for an
hour problem disappears and we and we
often see that you get the accusation
that you're a sellout or this one's a
racist and then the second you push back
boom their 2d platform you or whatever
else is by the way funny thing about
this story
she's a CNN legal analyst first time I
stole out the bisland I mean I'm doing
my show my producer I think was Edwin
jumped in my ear look at the TV her
first return that we know of to CNN was
to comment on jussie Smollett there's
car very mysterious ways but you know I
want people to take something from it
not just the audio clip which you know
they've heard and and the stories that
went over the story here is that offer
someone a conversation challenged them
to come in but use it to tell others
that this is why you shouldn't assume
believe or at least be willing to engage
and that was really what I took out of
it and I deliberately kept the story
going from my purse my perspective for
others not for her because it was no
longer about her so I got as a guy
that'sthat's worked through the radio
industry which is a tough freakin
industry that a lot of people want to
get into it's great don't do it don't do
it but if you do it and survive it's
pretty great you get to do what you love
for a living I mean where you see I mean
the the precept the the premise that she
had there that you would be fighting
racism the entire time going up through
your career did you see it the entire
time when you walk into Sirius XM are
they throwing stuff at you everybody has
different experiences and my belief
system is part of our experiences or how
we interact with the world couple bullet
points
than when I started in radio I started
in rock radio because I love the music I
grew up knowing a lot of the artists so
it was a natural fit people didn't see
me because I could talk about something
they cared about so I could sit out with
long hair earring tattooed guy a poison
concert in 1987 with Lita Ford and
Whitesnake you know and I or Joe Cocker
and Stevie Ray Vaughan and we can talk
about things and amazingly nobody kind
of went to color because once you remove
the veil by how you act people may have
a moment but they tend to come over to
your side and when I went to
entertainment talk and when I did a show
with Willie D from the ghetto boys all
right conservative David Webb yeah
Willie D ghetto boys gangster rap out of
the fifth Ward in Houston and we don't
agree on politics but we agreed on
something which was we were trying to
save people in the black community and
Willie I gotta tell you was one of hell
of a good guy on that and that's what we
did we focused on what we could do
together so I didn't see the are there
racists in the world yet did somebody
have a bias against me you know I don't
care because I'm not gonna let it stop
me if I can't go through you I'm gonna
go around you and that's my approach to
it that's how my parents raised me they
said find a path work your way through
it and just do what you can do the best
of your ability and if you have to
readjust hey that's life did you just
say that slightly backwards or do we
just have a different approach on life I
would try to go around them before
through you said through them so it's
like marine you know maybe maybe the
better way to put it is work your way
through it yeah all right debate the
issue but also the other point is it's
that one-to-one interaction or that idea
dydy interaction I've had my mind
changed on criminal justice reform for
instance and it was by a conversation
with or through a conversation with
Bernie Kerik former police commissioner
I'm all that was hard on this you know
this is ridiculous
you throw I don't care why you chose to
do that first thing you did it
but he walked me through it and you know
I was during the show
our hour-long interview I said you know
Bernie you convinced me I'm gonna
rethink this and I'll change my mind
that's a level of integrity that I ask
everyone to go for yeah so one of I know
I've told you this story many times and
it's in it's in my book so now I could
be a guy that says that we're being
quite about that except for pre-sales
right no yeah retails are available yeah
but I write about this in my book as I
talk about my political awakening and
one of the key moments of the whole
thing when I was on The Young Turks for
our left Network a long time ago and I
was still a lefty but I had this inkling
that something was not right that it
couldn't be that everyone they disagreed
with it was racist he couldn't be that
they were so right and everyone else was
so wrong and then one day were do
another there's four of us I think on
the panel and I believe you were guest
hosting for Sean Hannity that yeah it
was Sean and you know I'm on the panel
but I think it was three white guys and
they're all going that so they didn't
know that I knew you and they're all
going this David Webb guy he's he's a
self-hating black guy he's a sellout
give me some of the terms here well I
believe that Fox News Uncle Tom oh
that's that was the one then really yeah
because this was the whole idea I had
sold out because black people didn't
belong here right so so I hear them
saying all these things about you little
do they know I'm your friend and I'm
watching them say these things and I
think you know he doesn't believe any of
this stuff and all that and we've worked
through these issues so many times that
I know you are honest and decent and
believe the things that you talk about
and and suddenly it hit me because then
I look to this guy to my left and I
think who's the bigot here who's really
the bigot here is a black man who's
saying what he thinks and you but the
privileged in your words white guy
you're upset that a black man thinks
something different than you want them
to think who is the racist and it really
was one of the one of the final straws
for me before I fully went into this
mode or whatever you want to call this
thing now you know
I've known you long enough and I think I
can say this you're honest and honesty
and integrity is the core of what we do
whether you're talking about I don't
care what the topic is or what the
format is if you have integrity and you
have a point of honesty that stays there
are fixed you know the old True North
that's gonna be your belief system the
other thing is I've known you long say
you believe in doing the things try and
exceed what they're all about
okay I'm not thinking pretty close up
yeah and I believe in the same thing
because I've been in these situations
before like or like the arriva situation
I've been in the situations like you
talked about
and it's because I've gone out and
looked around and taken a chance by
experimenting with what's the idea how
do I counter it can i substantiate or
defeat the argument and if I'm honest
with myself and you're honest with
yourself eventually you see the
dishonesty around you and or the
unwillingness to even engage in it and
that's what they were trying to do with
the young turks because the video went
viral and we covered it on TV it was Fox
News Uncle Tom Tea Party founder this
was this he had to be this and I said
wow you know nothing about me right I am
that line also about because the whole
meme was that the Tea Party was racist
and here's one of the Tea Party founders
and here's a white guy I don't think I
can actually do it anymore we've known
each other way too long but I got to
blow maybe some listeners minds yeah my
tea party organization in New York City
right the launch of the original my
executive director was a 50 year old
Democrat she still is my two guys that
still endemic still Democrats right
fiscally conservative strong believer in
the Constitution that we can have our
differences all school Daniel Patrick
Moynihan style democrat yeah Lisa's a
sweetheart yeah the two guys because
they were in the industry in the
creative industry that ran my market and
had been partners for about thirty years
one of my other guys my guys was an
evangelical would never spend that much
with two gay guys in there and you know
what they became friends so you start to
see this mix of people because we had a
common core and believe that this
country needed to have an assessment of
where it was so I had a tea party group
that wasn't I guess the right-wing
evangelical white hood where and you
know team going out there and these were
the people who had common beliefs and I
was in New York City you know this we
have so many such a range and I'm proud
of that because these people still talk
to each other I still hear from them
there was an MIT student you know it's
just so odd to hear this range of Ages
what do you make of I'm glad that you
mentioned in know Patrick Moynihan
because when people ask me what kind of
liberal I still believe that I am it's
getting harder to say it but what kind
of liberal am i I always say when I say
JFK and Daniel Patrick Moynihan and I'll
say Ed Koch sometimes too Oh ed was a
great guy and I knew ed well he was one
of the greatest guys out there well that
he was a true New Yorker right I mean
the mayor of New York for how many years
like good good 12 years like that and
and he wanted to be out there with the
people anyone leaves was buried there
but he wanted to be out there with the
people we're now politicians really seem
so disconnected from the people and he
had that that feeling well he not only
had it but he still has it and I'll tell
you why we have a mutual friend Ed and I
and Philip and Philip would have
receptions at his business and I won't
put his last name into it for the sake
of a big big player in the country in
law and other things and he would have
Ed Koch and he would bring you name it
into this room and we'd all meet with
all talk and we'd all eat and we'd share
ideas I you know spend some time
everybody I've known Rudy Giuliani for
years and Rudy and I again just you know
probably what a week ago or so and over
the last several weeks we've been
talking about mayor's we'll sit out for
dinner or usually ends with cigars and
having a good time and he recognizes Ed
for who he is and he recognizes
Bloomberg who is why because these men
while they had their differences had a
similarity New York City
Rudy told me the story I didn't know the
story of how Edie got buried at Trinity
he's Jewish and how they came up with
this
they found this rabbi who explained that
you could consecrate a part of this
cemetery for his burial and there's a
respect between them yeah they know
their differences but there's a healthy
respect because of their commonality and
that tells you something in an off road
aiming there for you Jack Kemp a Jack
Kemp Republican Jack was another guy
these are men who are not out of their
time they need to have more people like
that yeah but I think that those guys
that you're talking about that is that
middle that I think a bunch of us now
are trying to give some energy to and I
do believe it's working so that that's
what makes us want to do it but do you
you wouldn't prefer that that daniel
patrick moynihan or ed koch or JFK
returned strongly to the democrats right
even if even if it costs you guys let's
say the Republicans you would still
prefer to have an honest broker to deal
with right well I mean first of all I
believe we're still gonna win here's
what should happen I think we need more
real parties and here's one of my
disappointments with libertarians you
have a Republican you have Democrat I do
prefer they would come back and research
but I don't believe in just the
two-party system
I want a multi-party system not too many
like in Israel where 60,000 people can
literally change the makeup of your
country right you can have an absurdly
get a certain amount yeah
but over the years from Ron Paul who I
think failed the libertarians massively
because he didn't build an
infrastructure I've said to libertarians
build your state parties find a few key
states build an infrastructure because
in politics you need an infrastructure
and grow your party so they can have a
debate you can have a real third party a
viable third party right but they don't
do that work they just go for the
presidency every four years and then
it's just you know and if you go for the
marketing and you don't build a good
product you know what you have failure
yeah
and it's worse than failure in a way
because it's then you look more
ridiculous each time yes I mean when you
get the outliers that come out in the
so ridiculous and people go well why
would I want to be a part of that crazy
but to you as a Republican do you fear
that okay so let's say they're
libertarians a lot of libertarians watch
this show obviously most of my political
leanings are libertarian wouldn't you
fear that what that does then is all
right now we get a libertarian party
that's at ten percent it just took eight
percent of that from the Republicans
congratulations we now have socialist
comrade Elizabeth Warren I don't and
I'll tell you why one like you I believe
in the Constitution in the system and
when I was a kid my father said you know
and I remember the exact words but
basically real strength real conviction
is that when something doesn't benefit
you is it the right thing you know in
other words where I think so the
Constitution is my guide and the fact
that we can have this debate and the
ability to correct in this country we
have a cultural DNA in the Declaration
of Independence we have a legal DNA in
the Constitution and the Bill of Rights
and we have the Federalist Papers and
other things but what it frames is this
idea that the country can self correct
the Supreme Court can make a decision
the other branches can get involved with
their respective roles and we can
correct things we we've fixed things in
this country and it's difficult and it
should be we don't want easy flip-flops
so I don't fear a Libertarian Party
that's strong I want it because I think
in help the other parties self-correct
you know more strength more voices not
less more strength to me is better a
strong nation is less challenged by
outsiders what I want a weak nation well
I want a stronger nation and I we can
weather the challenges yeah as far as
for the Socialists we do have an issue
here in this country and I think there
is a level of ignorance willful
ignorance and ideology combined that's
dangerous anything is when it magnifies
enough and it gets a loud voice and it's
used and abused by many out there who
actually don't even know the difference
that's a danger because what it does is
it robs people of that the part of their
life especially when you're younger when
you should be building towards your
future and once you've lost a chunk of
that how do you get it back
that's a danger yeah so what do we do to
change the factory settings of how
people are brought up it's a it's a
phrase that my friend Bridgette fat is
he came up with to this whoo I think
it's really perfect now basically the
factory settings if you grow up in
America are all sort of lefty or
democratic factory settings you know we
should take from some and give to the
other the government is somehow
inherently good while all of these Pot
the policies of the Democrats are just
like the thing that you're just sort of
basically taught and then you go from
there we're in my view the factory
settings we should all get would
actually be very libertarian it would be
all about freedom and individual rights
and individual liberty and then you
figure out well where do we actually
need government and that's why I can
still consider myself a classical
liberal or not a libertarian because I
do believe there is some utility for the
state it's just it's just real politics
right I want to jump in yes what I would
prefer is if education would get
everybody to the point of understand the
Constitution understand the documents
you just laid out so that we are free
first right then let's have the argument
about when we when we need government
but we do it the other way we do it that
the government is inherently good they
gave you all the rights they're supposed
to give you this stuff and free this
free that man and then occasionally
somebody on the right can come in and
maybe move that down a little bit but it
seems to me that we're doing this thing
upside-down decades of building a
political system that's based on a
career not service building a support
system in a bureaucracy and call it a
large interest whatever that interest
may be that supports the bureaucracy we
have a system that more resembles a
dinosaur in too many ways which is a
small brain a huge animal and
inefficient system and one that doesn't
recognize its receive the deathblow on
one end of the body because the brain is
not equipped for it and that's what I
see and where we are now
the self-correct on this I think is more
evident in parts of the country that
don't get the attention
Liman whalemen cheyenne somewhere out
and Paxton Nebraska in other areas where
people don't wake up every day and see
things the way you and I do they'll
check the Twitter and the president
don't checks Sanders wire you know they
didn't live in this those are the people
we have to engage I still believe and I
see it anecdotally and I think it's
supported by a lot of the studies that
there are more people in this country
that if they're engaged are that silent
majority
now whether they're right or left I
think they fall more in the American
cultural value system they don't fear
freedom but maybe they don't understand
fully the risk and reward that comes
with freedom there's there's risk yeah
there there's risk when what you're
describing happens when we go upside
down when it comes to freedom we've got
to realize that its inherent risk and
reward is why it works and I think there
are more of those people out there that
are coming to that Center the problem is
they haven't been engaged properly by
either party and they need to be brought
into it what do we do then to make more
let's say inclusive right this is this
isn't one of the interesting things that
I find right now most of my audience is
it's a little hard to say but I would
say it's something like half of my onus
is probably former lefties and a huge
percentage of those people they're still
like ah those people on the right like I
may think the less nuts but those people
on the right are really they're
everybody's nuts Husain right
everybody's nuts who's saying but that's
what I'm trying to show them in that
it's not the case because what I have
consistently seen is that the right
while not being perfect and nothing is
something like gay marriage for example
the right now has basically well nobody
talks about gay marriage anymore
nobody's fighting for gay marriage to be
reversed there is literally nobody doing
it the voices in the Republican Party
that we're rapidly against it saying
Mike Huckabee and Rick Santorum really
have no power in the Republican Party
anymore
so I've seen an ability to to be
flexible intellectually on the right
what is it that you guys can do to
to further that if you think that that's
a good thing to do well no I think it is
a good thing to do to evolve again I
trust the Constitution the people to
make as a whole the better choice not
pure democracy not mob rule but to make
a better choice based on some things
that they do control in some things they
don't control back in the 80s if you had
a black friend you were cool by the mid
to late 80s if you had a gay friend you
know you were really cool that both you
were like man I'm hanging in the club
exactly but there's a truth there
because what happened Generation started
to evolve those people who were cool
suddenly saw people differently you know
like how teammates each other I know you
may come from that side and that side
but we're playing on the same team which
is the American team so as the
generation evolves the parties didn't
always evolve the Republican Party
failed to engage blacks and urban
neighborhoods because they had a
strategy from 85 with the evangelicals I
get it
reality a political party right red
state blue state Republican Democrat
County carmem up you get your wins I get
mine we play were redistricted so the
party's failed but the culture is
evolving and the party has to come along
eventually problem is the party takes
longer to come along I don't have to
agree with someone and that's not
required neither is my offense or
someone else's offense necessary because
it's about freedom and I think the
people will drag it along which is why I
still hold more faith in the Millennials
then people on the right or left do are
there ones that are troublesome yes but
are there more of them in this country
what do you do as I do it I've been
every state and I've talked to people
and I see more people who are saying
just let me live let me do what I can do
to get my life where it is and stop
trying to sell me on what I need to
believe
yeah and we're really seeing that now
with the generation behind the
Millennials you know the the 16 year
olds now who are not you know the 22
year old social justice work right you
signal in crowd yeah that they now their
younger brothers and sisters are now
going
right with that well but it's happened
before see this is you go back to the
80s for a minutes go back was a future
all right
really the rewind machine this way what
happened for blacks in this country you
had a large influx during the growth of
the HBCUs you know the real growth you
had affirmative action you had more
blacks going to colleges you had all of
this come out of the 70s and 80s but it
took time for them to graduate and kind
of grow into the system so they couldn't
stop the march of blacks economically
culture yeah historical voting Democrats
parents are Democrats grandparents still
there but this slowly erosion if you
belong to us started back then so
Bleck citizen knew just a recognition of
recognition of the term is new it's
happenin anyway right you're buying a
little spot of land you're buying a
townhome you're keeping your credit
rating up now you're sending your kids
to someplace better what's happening
that's the evolution of generations so
I'm glad you mentioned legs because I
wanted to bring up Kandace related to
all this so it seems to me that part of
the reason that the Democrats are now
screaming about reparations is because
Candace Owens has been so almost
single-handedly effective at talking to
the I hate the phrase the black
community or the gay community thank you
but talking to black America let's say
which also has its limits as affairs but
talking to popular and just saying she
always says it she says it's the least
what I'm really saying is the least
controversial thing you could say which
is black people don't have to be
Democrats nobody has to be anything
they're not born with a stamp yeah look
it's a black Democrat white baby right
so she always says her message actually
even though she can throw some fire
bombs out there for sure her message
actually is incredibly uncontroversial
in a normal society but it seems to me
that she caused such upheaval in the way
that the media talks about black people
and that that after Kanye tweeted that
thing that suddenly all the hit pieces
on Kanye it's like that same game we
always see with
you should be in a mental institution a
sellout he's an uncle Ptolemies house
negro he's got Stockholm Syndrome yes
you've heard all about it you've heard a
walk but but it seems to me that she
caused such a awakening that now
reparations have become the norm on the
Left when Barack Obama would have never
thought about talking about reparations
and and he in a way now is a dinosaur of
the Democrats he comes off now a guy
that I'm guessing you disagree with him
every policy now comes off as pretty
Center wouldn't you say relative to the
to the crew now well appearances can be
deceiving I'll leave that on the table
with him because I watch this history to
where he got but here's what's happened
in a lot and a large part in the black
community and in the American
communities I like you I don't like the
segregation but I recognize the reality
of what it is blacks and whites and any
other ethnic group in America have
started to look at their personal life
and their economy and their opportunity
more than they're looking at parties
so the message will resonate more when a
Candace Owen steps up and says step away
what did Trump do during the campaign
cycle it was blunders what the hell do
you have to ask and you know what how
many people say some things aren't
working in my life what the hell do I
have to lose let me try something else
it was that recognition that something's
broken right somebody pulled the fire
alarm there's a problem everybody's
running around their hair's on fire
lights and sirens are going off but they
already knew something was wrong so now
they're wondering so what do you do if
you're left then I call it the
regressive progressive left what do you
do you now have to create enemies and
fear and fear works you tell people you
don't have it because those damn
Republicans I know you've been living in
Baltimore with 50 years of liberal rule
and and West Baltimore is a s hole and
this is it cuz you're living with it but
it's the white guy living over in Howard
County's fault Yeah right all right so
all right really
yeah or every time that somebody brings
up I mean Hannity deals with this all
the time you know if he brings up the
shootings in Chicago
and he talks about the black-on-black
violence in Chicago they tell him he's
racist and it's like well how could one
the black you were talking about it how
come when the black criminal uses the
gun to commit a crime in a
majority-black neighborhood
it's the criminals fault when the white
guy uses a gun it's the guns fault
somebody please sort that one out for me
yeah that would cause some heads to yeah
but this is this is simple stuff people
are starting to see this technology and
social media you and I are you know on
on all these different platforms
podcasts YouTube approximation whatever
technology and social medias Pierce in
the veil more and more kids whether
they're still get in the same images are
getting more images more imagery more
information on smartphones on tablets on
computers little by little that is
Pierce in the veil and in whether you're
in a bad neighborhood good neighborhood
everywhere in between you know that
information is out there so we have a
job to do you and I give people the
information help guide them yes we our
beliefs are our beliefs we have a right
to push those out there but help guide
people to not only listen to why we
believe what we do but at the same time
go figure out what your beliefs are and
then substantiate them and technology
media social media all of this look it
can be misused abuse and it is yeah but
it can be used and targeted where you
add on the regulation of the big tech
companies because it's a really
fascinating one right now but you've got
Tucker Carlson I'll do my piss hand you
got Tucker Carlson on the right and
you've got Elizabeth Warren on the left
both calling for the same thing which is
a pretty fascinating political spot and
I think maybe I told me was probably but
when I went to YouTube and I met with
Susan Wojcicki the the CEO of YouTube in
her office or in the conference room
Aaron I said I'm basically the last guy
not calling for regulation no I'm still
trying to play the libertarian thing I'm
still trying to find market answers to
this but that's that's becoming an
increasingly more minority position why
they're calling for it Tucker or war and
two different reasons based on their
ideologies and I'm with you
I this is a longer-term view I don't
want government stepping in and having a
hand in something because you can never
get their hand out of it or you can
rarely get their hand out pretty much I
believe in the free market it's a
patient game it's a long-term somebody
look somebody else is gonna cup along
with technology soon artificial
intelligence exam and we're gonna
exactly and I know others that are
working on competitive models so whether
it's five years ten years they will have
something in competition or they will
evolve or age out that's the nature of
business and I think that can work but
government getting involved is a danger
because of this simple reason if you're
a congressman it's a two-year cycle if
you're presidents for maybe eight years
if you're senator at six years so they
think in cycles and when the cycle
changes their solution which rarely is
the one you want is more dangerous
because somebody else can come along and
change it and misinterpret it right a
new regulation and ignore the basic
principles of let it work out and I say
this to Republicans I get it look my
facebook page
somehow just basically people don't get
my feeds yeah for a year plus I've been
effectively shut down I literally have
lost ninety percent of my reach at times
yeah they changed some metrics but I
didn't lose ninety percent overnight
right yeah ninety percent didn't just
drop right and the fact that they're so
untransparent makes you half the time
think you're a conspiracy theorist and
then in a weird way they're playing off
that right they never give you any
information so that they go oh we
changed a little bit it's a fan page
you're supposed to pay like they're
always trying to keep you guessing so
that you don't feel comfortable talking
about it cuz you don't want to sound
like well the difference between
conspiracy and reality for me is
probability and possibility what is
probable what is possible and on the
ends you have you know the reality which
we may never know in the conspiracy
I don't want government becoming the
overlord of any publishing platform
however I do want the antitrust
regulations to be reviewed I do want the
responsible bodies with all
site that we've elected them to do to go
in and say okay technologies evolve
companies have evolved does antitrust me
this are they acting like a model like
monopoly and a monolithic body and our
others allowed into the marketplace
which is different than Facebook saying
Instagram I want to buy you that's fine
yeah even if I don't like what some of
the effects oh you are so this so your
your premise your starting point I would
say is is basically the libertarian
position but then you're you're just
saying this has gone so extreme that we
don't have to do some stuff that you
don't want to do or actually don't maybe
don't want him to do anything but I
don't think about think about it and go
Warren wants control right that's what
she wants she doesn't want freedom she
wants control I just have to base that
on her writing since college her papers
that I have read her policy positions
Wells out of the danger also because
they call half of us Nazis so once they
have the power what do you think they're
gonna do to all the Nazis they would
learn if it's their moral duty to get
rid of the rest of us that's why you
don't want the government and the tech
companies in bed you I don't want to
make in that decision and where it goes
wrong in our country we do self-correct
within two hundred or forty forty to
forty ish forty ish forty three right
but even just okay let's even just go
back to the Constitution and when it was
really and the Bill of Rights and when
that was put in place in these years
that this country has been around what
have we gotten right over what we've
gotten wrong we've evolved we've
reversed the blight of slavery the
Atlantic slave trade women's rights
under Calvin Coolidge by the way a
Republican and his wife Grace Coolidge
who fought for that look at all the
things we've done and what we've
exported we've exported ideas and
freedom the nation's imperfect is we're
imperfect we'll make mistakes but our
ability to correct them is based in
something that's the core of this
country and I have more faith in that
than I do in the others now that doesn't
mean we don't need you know sheep dogs
out there to watch for the wolf was
hiding in the woods and it doesn't mean
that we don't have to protect because
the fact is the majority of people are
sheep not in necessarily a bad way I'm
not insulting all people but majority
people go along in their daily life they
make it work they make the economy work
the engine work they drive the trucks
work in the stores work on Wall Street
but sheepdogs are the ones who look out
for what's right and what's wrong even
if they don't agree with it and we need
more of that sheepdog approach yeah well
we need a little we need a little bit of
let's think about what we might be
getting ourselves into a knee-jerk
response look beyond what you think
that's why I'm afraid I said I'm afraid
of politicians in this sense they think
in cycles and we need long-term thinking
if a company makes a decision
economically on a factory or something
based on a twenty to thirty year
projection of trends and supply lines
and distribution and avenues for their
products whatever the case may be why
are we thinking in two four and six year
periods that's incredibly short-sighted
and dangerous yeah and that's something
we ought to consider so you're basically
a Trump guy right yeah I am a Trump
supporter and I you know knowledge of
him before he was president and now and
what I do or may not disagree with her
agree with but I have seen him do
something amazing in this country he
broke the emergency glass and said
they're not working for you
he didn't say Republicans they're not
working for you Democrats are not
working for you came down the escalator
and said folks it's not working that's
how I see it yeah is there anything that
just personality-wise or anything that
worries you or you feel it's a little
playing with fire or something like that
no because for all the lefties that I
told you about before that are coming
that are saying okay conservatives we
got you you're not what we thought
libertarians you're certainly not what
we thought there's this other firewall
or something thats related to Trump that
I think anybody'll that a big a figure
he exaggerated Sat times I've had
private conversations I've had public
interviews all right you know so I see
him in different ways I've seen him also
in ways that I wish more people would
I wrote an article about his interaction
with a terminal cancer patient he didn't
even know I was right actually I didn't
know I was writing it but I kind of made
that interaction happen and it no
cameras no nothing so I've seen
different sides of him
you know the tweeting at times I'm like
I would have done it better
different I can actually tell him I
would have done it better okay
people always say that that it's the
tweeting that that they can't get over
but it's like he did break the system by
tweeting so Obama had a Twitter account
Trump weaponized it yeah he made it a
weapon because otherwise he would be
constantly a sale and I have no outlet
and media failed here because if media
was fair I really believed there would
be less of this barrage if you've been
under assault and you and he has he has
been under assault and he's a
counter-puncher and yes he's big and
bigger than life television personality
personality as a whole who he is from as
younger I can't ago that's it but what I
do is I go underline like the river
here's this big rough water up top and
then you go longer and you see what runs
deep the policies the work being done by
the agencies HUD the the the Small
Business Administration changes in
regulation unleash in parts of America
that need to build that can outlast his
presidency full disclosure I'm part of
the committee to unleash prosperity
found it by Forbes Kudlow laugher and
stand more and before Trump we were
working on this program policy approach
we all have our roles I'm not the
economist I can convey the policy
message but this is what was put in
place bringing a team of rivals find a
way to swim with the sharks try to make
it so that the foundation changes
evolves and is better and then let that
go to work and when you're out of the
White House because he will be despite
all the people that think he's not
leaving the White House and I saw an eye
that said 2044 yeah okay there are times
I just like the Donald please don't but
when you talk to the guy you sit in a
room and I know people that have known
him a lot longer than I have you have
this different personality and I think
that's not that different for many of
these public figures how much attention
do you think people should pay to all of
this that's one of the things you know
when I did my own grade August that was
one of the things that I spent a lot of
time thinking about that we all care we
want to be engaged people that watch
these shows the ones your show it's like
there's a beauty in a weird way for as
hysterical as everyone seems there's a
beauty right now because people are
actually reading what they think they're
reevaluating what side they're on
they're reevaluating who they can talk
to so there is a beauty to it that that
is under the layer of craziness but
sometimes I am worried that the
obsession with all of this the the
obsession with either what Trump tweeted
or the latest stupid thing that AOC said
it's keeping us really off-balance just
as people all right it's just not
healthy for a society no I mean there's
an unhealthy aspect of it if you when I
say you the person don't understand it
for what it is or at least try to maybe
none of us I think fully understands
even ourselves because we all grow
evolve different experiences you know
keep on me this is you my Bourbons in
yeah well you know excuse me yeah I'd
like to order no seriously I know what
Twitter is all right let's use Twitter
as an example or any social media so I
go on and I throw a grenade in the room
and I walk away and I see what happens
because I know what it is it's a toy you
know you go out for a month and I throw
something leave for 24 hours and watch
Alyssa Milano's husband go that's I find
people don't understand that some of
this isn't real life you can convey a
real life using the platform but is it
really real life to use bio is it on
Twitter that says Twitter is not real
life I don't know that is but
pretty wise guy pretty wise guy yeah and
you know social media and all these
components are not that this with people
watching and I hope they're interacting
with us by thinking for themselves at
the same time excuse me the same time
that's real life and we realize that
these are tools people you know they
hate you get it on Twitter you're sure
that I have a I have an entire file but
I don't keep the file because I need to
know the file I get the file because I'm
like wow that was pretty I know like
clever you need to improve on that can
you do better I've heard that one before
you get like a truly original one and
yeah I give them credit I don't agree
with what you say but I have a guy on
Twitter I think it's Rick Rock or
whatever and he's a Jersey guy and he
will occasionally come at me okay well
when I put up something and he has the
guts to say yeah okay I couldn't think
of that and then five seconds later yeah
yeah I gotta ask you I don't know that
I've ever asked you this your voice
which is an all-star radio voice did you
always have that deep gravelly I know
you've had some surgery over the years
on your throat and stuff but did you
always have that from when you I always
had the deep voice you know when puberty
ends you find out which way which way
it's going yeah I had one polyp but that
didn't really make a difference thank
God yeah you know that didn't do it it's
just there it's what I have okay some of
it to be fair is tired and working from
time to time and you go through that I
mean I was up at 3:00 a.m. this morning
flying through three cities just to get
I came across States just to get here
but it's also part of the coaching and
the delivery that we all do so
professionally you and I do what we do
what do we focus on our delivery and
don't worry about what you don't have
cuz little secret I don't like to listen
to my shows I I hated air check sessions
I hated sitting over my PD and gotta
listen to myself really but you have to
check and you have to do it use what you
got
somebody's gonna like it somebody's not
gonna like it just be what it is and
there's a lot of guys out
there were deeper voices than me they're
not all day Barry White yeah you ever
guest host any of the rock channels now
does that move your passion before I
grew up with music and entertainment
always loved music never had the talent
to play I played around the drums a
little too piano you know typical things
but I know music in all its forms
there is classical that I like there's
rock there's metal there's hip-hop
there's a but I always seem to fall into
music and entertainment when rapper's
delight' came out of East Orange New
Jersey I was in high school at the same
time DJing so we got to know each other
when KC and the Sunshine Band or coming
out what all these things were coming
together I was in New York for the music
scene when you know late nights at the
Palladium when blondie would come in
when Pat Benatar Billy Squier the
Ramones Joey and DeeDee well you know
when all this things the China Club late
nights Nordoff Robbins so I grew up with
this and what I have a love for is I
respect art same way you respect a
painting or a beautiful classic car it's
a creation so I always loved that I love
music it's now I get away you get away
for a month I crank it up and I go and I
will go through the moods man I will put
on Mazursky and play pictures in
exhibition or I'll put on the EOP
version and listen to Greg Lake who was
a longtime friend play his version just
it depends
it's like bourbon and scotch it's my
mood its lifestyle I think we did it all
by man no we got lots more to go is
there you and I okay I'll be the day
when your hurts God yeah although you do
it beautiful hair well you know it's a
lot of spray in there let's face it I've
got gravel all right well we will we're
not gonna wait five years how about that
know what I'm doing I'm literally doing
your daily literally doing
I show tomorrow so there you go for more
on that damage follow them on the
Twitter although he throws some bombs at
David Webb show hand grenades if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell